fue una de las principales promesas de
campaña del presidente manuel marco
ayudar a los franceses a hacer frente al
aumento del costo de vida tras largas
horas de debate la asamblea nacional
votó un proyecto de ley para proteger el
poder adquisitivo de los ciudadanos el
paquete de 20 mil millones de euros
incluye aumento del 4% en las pensiones
hasta seis mil euros de bonificaciones
libres de impuestos para empresas
privadas y un tope del 3.5 por ciento en
aumentos de alquileres la aprobación de
este paquete se dio en un parlamento
dividido por un lado la bancada del
presidente ma con el partido conservador
los republicanos y la extrema derecha
quienes apoyaron la medida por otro la
izquierda representada por la alianza
que votó en contra al criticar que el
paquete incluye la reapertura de una
central eléctrica de carbón y la
importación de gas estadounidense a
pesar de las promesas de mayo de
proteger el ambiente
el artículo 13 de este proyecto de ley
propone una decisión suicida al aumentar
las importaciones de energía fósil en
francia
es una medida excepcional defendida por
el gobierno para compensar una crisis
energética inminente provocada por la
guerra de ucrania se trata de sustituir
la energía fósil por otra energía fósil
que es exactamente igual en cuanto a la
molécula es el gas natural a la mayoría
ma cronista le espera otra prueba una
nueva ronda de debates para un proyecto
de ley de finanzas que podría incluir
descuentos en los combustibles lo que le
costaría al gobierno francés miles de
millones adicionales